it looks like bioshock 4 will not be
returning to rapture or colombia
control's next gen upgrade will only
come with the ultimate edition
and capcom is undecided on its next-gen
prices
i'm persia and you reach your safe state
for wednesday august 12th
we don't have much information on
bioshock 4 yet but some new job listings
from the developers cloud chamber
suggest that the next installment will
not be returning to rapture
or colombia there were a few listings
that confirmed obvious details like
running on unreal engine 4 and being
slated for next-gen but one listing in
particular for a lead environment
modeler
is looking for someone who will help
breathe life into a new
and fantastical world the wording
suggests that the new bioshock won't be
returning to rapture colombia for the
new installment and like bioshock
infinite will create
its own world bioshock 4 is still
several years away but it should be
interesting to see how a team of both
bioshock veterans and new hires
will progress the series it may be a new
world but when it comes to game play
what do you want to see make a return
remedy entertainment announced that it
will be showing off its next expansion
for control tomorrow
alongside a new all-inclusive edition of
the game called the
ultimate edition which will also land
you a free next-gen upgrade
it's important to note that the ultimate
edition will be the only way to get a
free upgrade to a next-gen version of
control
which means if you currently own the
base game and season pass
you aren't eligible for the free nextion
upgrade with no word yet
on if you can purchase this upgrade
separately down the line
the ultimate edition is coming to steam
on august 27th for 40 dollars and
plan to be available for xbox one and
ps4 at a later date
but be sure to stop by gamespot.com
tomorrow for all the details on remedy's
world premiere of control's newest
expansion
and while we're on the topic of next-gen
there's been a lot of talk about
next-gen game prices increasing
with games like nba 2k already confirmed
to be 70 us bucks
on ps5 in the series x but after its
latest earnings call capcom is currently
undecided on changing its prices
capcom is in a wait and see period on
whether or not to increase the prices of
its next-gen games
saying that it will consider our
approach having analyzed both
our strengths and weaknesses while
closely monitoring industry trends
capcom also noted that first quarter
revenues have exceeded
expectations mostly due to strong
digital sales players have been worried
about price increases however
others like ubisoft have already
indicated that ps5 and xbox series x
games will be 60
bucks through this fall so we'll just
have to wait and see what comes our way
when the next gen is finally here before
you go don't forget to check out
storage.gamespot.com where we've got
some awesome play for all merch for sale
and all of those proceeds are being
donated to support black lives matter
and
kobit 19 relief efforts our donation
drive is still going strong through the
end of august which gives you a few more
weeks to help out
thanks so much for tuning in guys you
can follow me on twitter at project
underscore xo
and as always make sure you reach your
next save state tomorrow
happy wednesday
[Music]
you